[Music]
hey what's up I'm Kim BHD here so
hear me out ps5's controller
this guy right here might be
might be the best part of the PS5 but
maybe an even hotter take as this might
be the most next-gen thing about any of
the upcoming next-gen consoles it's
important like of course the graphics
are gonna get better and the games will
look better but the controller evolving
maybe that's a hot take but I think this
is pretty important so both major
consoles Xbox series and PlayStation 5
right around the corner as you know and
I'm testing them both it's a lot of hard
work playing a lot of games between the
two of them of course but I wanted to
take a minute before the reviews of them
to talk about controllers so a lot of
you have seen the PS5 unboxing so you've
seen that new controller and this is it
and I didn't unbox the Xbox series X and
S on camera but I've shown it several
times already and these are the Xbox
controllers the series X comes with a
black controller matte black everything
actually and the series s comes with a
matte white controller but it's the same
thing roughly it's not super new and
we've seen the shape before there's some
subtle improvements I like though USB
type c and there's a DOT pattern on the
back of the shoulders that's really nice
now but the ps5's new controller is
different it's built different it's it's
uh I don't know how many people are
actually shopping between PlayStation 5
and Xbox series X like to be honest I
think most people already know which one
they want and they're just seeing how
they can get their hands on them
pre-orders that whole dance but if you
are still undecided
maybe the controller is that
differentiating factor so okay why am I
making this whole video why is the
controller so different well I already
showed you the fundamental new thing the
new beefier design the new lights the
new USB type c and the pins at the
bottom for the dock and even that crazy
detailed texture that's all fine but
also this controller when it turns on
has a feel that makes you feel more
connected to the game and the console I
mean it's a controller so it's the one
thing that you can actually say maybe
more than the screen actually connects
you to the game so two things about it
first the new haptics are very strong
there's a new haptic motor inside this
think like the difference between a new
phone the newest iPhone's haptic motor
and like an old sloppy traditional
vibration motor that Precision to it and
then the other thing is the Adaptive
triggers so I mentioned in the unboxing
when you just kind of squeeze the
triggers when the controller is off they
feel normal but when the controller is
on they have an Adaptive level of
resistance of when you actually pull
them down and the level of resistance
can get pretty high and you really have
to squeeze the triggers and they respond
based on what's happening on the screen
and in the game so those two things are
a feel that is a major step up so
together they make up the Dual sense
controller and then to demo it Sony
actually made a game it's called Astros
playroom to show it off and it has
exaggerated levels of haptics and
adaptive triggers all throughout the
game and they combine with the speaker
and the controller to really feel super
engaging all the time I was going to say
immersive I don't know if that's the
right word but it's just engaging the
whole time so in this game you basically
control Astro and go through this world
this is one stage called cooling Springs
and literally Everything You Touch feels
different through the controller the
character walking around on glass you
feel the footsteps it feels and sounds
one way but even without the sound it
just feels noticeably different than
walking on metal or walking through
water or on Sand and that feel is all
translated by the haptic motor that
moves the controller with every footstep
really precisely it's pretty great with
hitting things the impact is different
for different materials so of course
there's going to be a lot of different
things to hit all over this game
constantly to feel all that happen coins
hitting you feels different from hitting
a leaf feels different from hitting an
enemy and then for the Adaptive triggers
they tie it to this feeling of a spring
in the game so you're using the Triggers
on the back of the controller to squeeze
down a spring and the added resistance
plus the haptic vibration all kind of
feel exactly how it would feel if you
were trying to squeeze and compress a
real life spring it is a very convincing
combination of haptics I'm gonna use
this feeling for other things too like
the stretching of rope when you pull on
ropes in the game which again happens a
lot
but yeah it's clearly a it's a
tailor-made experience around all the
strengths of the new controller so of
course there's entire levels and and
places that are just around the feel of
your environment and the haptics through
the controller on your hands but it is a
really good demo and so when I when I
demo this I'm using this new controller
I'm reminded of how whenever I use a new
phone with a really good haptic motor I
appreciate it way more and it feels
newer and more next-gen than phones from
a couple years ago or even this year
with bad vibration Motors they feel
worse and you never really unnoticed
that it also reminds me of the MacBook
Pro's trackpad the new trackpad where
the force touch you would swear the
glass is moving but it's not it just has
a really good high quality haptic motor
right behind it that feels like a very
convincing real click and that's in a
much smaller space than this controller
where they can fit much bigger haptic
Motors so there's a lot going on in here
so Sony published a teardown of the
PlayStation 5 and it was pretty cool and
a lot of people watched it it was very
detailed but what I want to see now is
what the inside of the controller looks
like and some people are already doing
that I think Austin did a video on the
internet of looking at how big these
haptic Motors are so of course I can't
tear this one apart because it's a
review unit but I feel like we're going
to see a lot more of that very soon it's
just when you have more space you can do
more with haptics and that to me feels
much more next-gen and noticeable and I
also want to point you to this dave2d
video he made a really good video just
with a really good animation slash
illustration of what the triggers and
the motor behind them may look like how
they add resistance to the squeezing the
triggers Dave I hope you don't mind me
using this but it's really good and I
think here you can visualize now better
how they use the motors to make the
triggers harder to squeeze but
definitely check out just watch Dave's
entire video I'll link it below we share
a lot of the same thoughts on this
controller but uh watch the rest of his
entire video as well so better haptics
better feel in the thing you're actually
holding that connects you more
physically to the game than the actual
graphics
when you think about it as kind of a
no-brainer but I think now the question
now that we have this pretty good
controller is what other games are going
to actually take advantage of it so Sony
built Astros World cool demo but what
other games are actually going to use
these impressive you know physical
achievements inside the controller the
first thing that comes to mind for me is
shooting games right having the
squeezing the trigger and having the
resistance of actually squeezing the
trigger might feel different for
different guns that I could definitely
see happening but then you know the
gears started to turn a little bit what
about driving games there's a lot of
those and something to notice anytime
you play a good driving game with a Good
Wheel the wheel has really high quality
haptics and vibration motor so when you
drive over different surfaces it feels
different in the wheel the vibration of
the car you feel it on the wheel that
can be done better with better quality
haptics through this controller so I can
see that happening but then there's all
kinds of adventure games like the
Spider-Man game there's sports games of
course I I play a lot of 2K so I imagine
feeling the basketball dribbling through
the controller and there's actually
moments where you you're shooting a free
throwing you feel the heartbeat of your
player through the controller that stuff
will be Amplified feel more convincing
on this new controller so there's a lot
of possibilities and I'm hoping that PS5
game developers are as amped about this
as I am that would be really exciting so
that's it for now short video just to
get the gears turning and think about
this a little bit but let me know what
you think is this haptic engine in this
controller whatever they want to call it
enough to convince you of PS5 over Xbox
or what do you how are you feeling about
this because I think this is exciting I
wanted to lift it sort of separate it as
a thought from the full reviews but
those are coming soon and of course much
more is in the pipeline as well thanks
for watching
catch you guys later
peace